pepe deixou as pessoas seu filho de uma
é pessoal já tô aqui no estúdio ia
gostar uma bosta são 11 23 da manhã e eu
tenho que fazer isso para explicar o que
aconteceu nestes quatro dias eu sei
fazer um resgate comigo por um vídeo em
que unisc postar um vídeo por dia e já
nomeou um vídeo há quatro dias mas não
teve uma de quatro dias porque eu tava
super ocupado a fazer as coisas que
postulam a montar o cenário montado
lúcia montadas camas montar tudo
resultado está aqui não aqui ela lembra
né
vejam só que se o pessoal fight night at
freddy's burlou o jogo acabou de ser por
isso podem contar com os vídeos este
blog mais um vídeo tempo e vamos ao que
interessa o pessoal que mostramos aqui o
cenário que vai acompanhar o canal em
2016 eu acho que está pronto e espero
que vocês gostem também 32 um novo fosse
eles não falarem sol deu imenso trabalho
é construir mas eu acho que ficou a
sangrar pelos polícias de margens na tua
opinião com significado não significa
assim deve isso vai focar aqui eu acho
que deve ser óbvio né quem tinha placa
dos eminentes críticos simboliza cada um
de vocês um movimento e não poderia
deixar de faltar neste cenário imagine
quando tiver a posse de um milhão tipo
eu vou fazer sexo anal com o placar que
é bastante também um vídeo que foi o
vídeo que eu mais me divertir fazer
muitas voltas quando me encontra na rua
no shopping fazer referência a este
vídeo está prestes a obter também é que
o campo e caíque do fat freddy's porque
está relacionado com placa de 100 mil
inscritos o campo que tem uma vela
aniversário especial eu assim inscritos
em tese é por aí
o quadro maior é do fred porque
basicamente texto foi o jogo perdeu
muito impulso ao canal ficará se não
fosse o facto é fredes muitos de vocês
nem conheciam eo tempo é jogar este jogo
com bem mas a gente foi e não é o fred
normal não se deixem enganar por que eu
tenha algo muito especial dentro do
quadro vocês podem ver no instagram me
buscar os príncipes querem ver o que é
que este quadro tão especial para ser um
extremo que vai mostrar o vídeo aqui eu
decidi fazer uma brincadeira como não
visa sempre que não foi à escola esta é
a mona lisa não esta é moneda e como eu
conto para crianças de star wars e fez
uma montagem com light saídas do verdão
5km carinha linda porque eu acho que o
nome está ficando mais bonito assim aqui
mas teria catarina minha namorada me
inspiro me com uma burca lá atrás eu
acho que está melhor moldura que está
aqui aqui tem uma moldura de ser o canal
tem o rodrigo não está associada ao
terror pronto é por isso é fruto do
américa não story of porque rolim você
pode agradar ao técnico do américa não é
a história que também é uma série que eu
gosto não viram button é que tem o buquê
é o fantasma um lado a nintendo ela
aparece em vários jogos está tudo
combinado está tudo um conceito abstrato
que também não já não sei que vou falar
bom eu acho que nem explicar aí mas eu
tenho que dois quadros que estão brasil
espanha colômbia a fundo mas eu já tenho
uma ideia para colocar neste quadro mas
isso vai ser feito mais para frente
mesmo assim se você tiver alguma
sugestão preocupada que digam aí nos
comentários e perceber né
está um cenário pessoal espero que vocês
tenham gostado e seu pai por ser no
fundo dos vídeos e não gostou do
estatuto completo já tenha respondido
todas as quadras e outro lá também mas
acho que só quis mostrar isso é que tem
em mãos e pés
aqui tem você tá tudo arrumado ainda
tenho que tomar os filhos os carros fios
de cabelo a mesma coisa a prontamente
como é que tá não pensei que tamanho é
quente aqui é o sensor dos jogos gift
aqui tem uma câmera catarina mim estou
eu fazer vídeos para ter mais qualidade
estão rindo light que é basicamente uma
luz que o dunga neto aproveita ilumina
muito bem e basicamente quando você joga
para us fique como é que uma rosinha no
meio do olho fica lá em cima de uma faca
em candal esponja que eu não sei por que
quiser mas o jec teto dizem que faz
várias funções no canto uma tecla de que
os bem pobres é que tem um rap réver que
ó seu gosto por deus porque eu tenho
aqui este button e chutões para evitar
vídeos da imensa gente este show jet set
que usam da reza está aquele o comando
dele um disco externo que uso para ter o
material da edição nos fóruns de cozinha
assim os fãs de rosa além disso a câmera
encantador portal da cimpor já é uma
coluna canal 1 501 bloco deverá ouvir
que não faz falta nenhuma pois aqui tem
que fazer o trabalho todo que é o meu pc
que neste momento é um tiro no chão eu
digo lá embaixo porque eu contava com a
sima fazer muito barulho disse fria com
o microfone inclusive um microfone pac
muita gente me pergunta que microfone
este é um ato vil técnica 2020 é uma
coisa assim se você tem um microfone em
casa e não tem um incrível eu faço como
o tempo é que eu tenho desde o microfone
basicamente foi arrancado deste campeã
no eu comprei expandir no iqa praia 8
euros e depois da conquista para cima e
colocar o microfone e isso funciona
perfeitamente com um tripé eu sair eu
sei que sou um gênio a minha câmera
provoque é uma sony action que é uma
branquinha ela tem muita qualidade mas
ultimamente não tem usado porque eu
estou sempre a tocar neste lento e
quando ele fica sujo estragou os vídeos
todos e é por isso que pela tenha usado
eo mais importante já está executando
uma caneta azul 11 ela dá choque às
vezes já não ficar sem bateria na câmara
por exemplo de falar muito rápido me
despir por isso é isso pessoal consular
que sobretudo porque eu tô fazendo assim
não sai como favorito fique bem e até a
próxima